et son invité avec Alain Joyandet
effectivement sénateur de Hute zone et
surtout chef de fil pour l'UMP pour les
régionales de 2015 on a terminé avant le
flash sur la capitale quel capitale pour
pour cette région vous vous envoyez deux
alors si je comprends bien moi je pense
qu'il faut faire de la politique
autrement y compris dans l'organisation
territoriale la Bourgogne et la
franchectée ont une force c'est les
territoires on n'est pas très nombreux
on va être 2800000 mais c'est pas la
peine d'être très nombreux il va
être moins nombreux et plus heureux
j'allais dire hein mais donc il faut
organiser nos services publics il faut
penser à nos territoires la force de la
Bourgogne franchecé ce sera ses
territoires ses richesses et donc il
faut organiser nos collectivités
territoriales et l'État parce qu'on
parle beaucoup de la réforme de la
région on parle jamais de la réforme
c'est l'État qui va décider la capitale
finalement non oui il y a il y a une
longue procédure on n pas le temps de
rentrer trop dans dans le détail mais ça
n'est qu'en 2016 que les les les la
décision définitive sera sera prise il
va y avoir un préfet préfigurateur qui
va êtreenommé nom donc déjà ça va nous
donner une idée sur ce que veut faire le
gouvernement j'attends avec impatience
cette décision qui est d'ailleurs
reportée de semaine en semaine pour
l'instant avrilant on espère on espère
et donc voilà il faut qu'on essaie de
répartir comme il faut je le disais tout
à l'heure il faut pas une fusion
absorption je le dis aussi pour les
Bourguignons c'est l'intérêt de la
Bourgogne de faire en sorte que les
franc-ontoin ne se sentent pas absorbés
mais qu'il se sentent associés c'est
tout à fait différent il y a donc la
préfecture de région et il y a le
conseil régional sont les deux forces
principales et bien moi je dis juste
qu'il faut que les deux choses
aujourd'hui ne soient pas dans la même
vie ça va pas être compliqué pour les
relations pas du tout mais pas du tout
vous savez très bien qu'aujourd'hui avec
les nouvelles technologies je pense
qu'il faut même aller au-delà je pense
qu'il faut penser aux autres
départements je pense qu'il faut penser
à nos autres à nos zones rural il faut
équiper tout ce monde là il faut
respecter nos territoires en tout cas si
l'intention du gouvernement est de
mettre tout dans la même ville je pense
que il y aura des problèmes pour cette
pour cette fusion et il faut être
absolument équitable dans l'organisation
il y a le CESR il y a plein de choses
qui qui qui peuvent être organisées
ensemble alors puisque vous parlez de
nouvelle technologie une question d'un
d'un internaute qui nous dit oui vous
vous dites que vous soutenez le
numérique mais dans les actes on voit
rien qu'est-ce que vous voulez faire
concrètement en fait pour le numérique
enambourgen franchecé ah ben je pense
que les régions qui vont être
compétentes un de mes engagements sur le
développement économique aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de développement économique
possible sans numérique ça a été mon
cheval de bataille depuis mon engagement
en politique j'avais fait de ma ville la
première dans ma viille la première
Cyber Base publique de France donc je
suis passionné par ce sujet il faut
absolument que la région aide les
départements parce que pour l'instant ce
sont les départements qui ont pris en
charge beaucoup de choses il faut les
aider il faut faire un ensemble Région
Département faut se donner un objectif à
la fin du prochain mandat il faut que
toute la franche comptée toute la
Bourgogne soit couverte en en haut débit
c'est absolument indispensable c'est ça
encore le le levier j'allais dire des
des élus et des futurs élus régionaux
pour favoriser l'emploi l'économie le
développement alors sur l'emploi et
l'économie j'ai une vraie stratégie
c'est deuxième pilier de mon projet
c'est relancer le développement
économique en Bourgogne franchecé il
faut absolument réussir cette fusion
faire des économies je pense qu'on peut
faire 2 % d'économie par an c'est quand
même pas beaucoup demandé et c'est
possible c'est un peu moins de 200000 €
par an ça permet de remettre de l'argent
dans l'économie il y aura pas que ces
économies là mais je parle des mais ça
représente pas grand-chose mais je je
dis je dis j'ai fait d'ailleurs sans
doute un lapsus on est on n pas sur
200000 € par an on exc excusez le lapsus
on est sur 20 million d'euros par an
évidemment puisquon aura un budget de 1
milliard 1 milliard 300 millions d'euros
he puisqu'on est d'un côté à peu près
800 millions l'autre côté à peu près 500
millions donc on peut trouver ces 20
millions d'euros par an sans sans grande
difficulté à mon avis il faut réinjecter
ça dans l'économie il faut accélérer le
processus de soutien aux entreprises en
difficulté je donne la priorité au
développement endogène plutôt qu'au
développement exogène ça ça qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'il faut
déjà s'occuper des entreprises
existantes avant d'aller chercher des
entreprises à l'extérieur occupons-nous
de tous ceux qui souffrent en terme
d'entreprise aussi bien les
entrepreneurs que les salariés aidons
les plus il faut rationaliser ce qui
existe actuellement en Bourgogne
franchecté 47 au total 47 procédures
pour aider les entreprises 47 vous avez
10 fond d'intervention financière ça
coûte 5 millions d'euros par an rien que
ça la réorganisation ça coûte 5 million
d'euros par an j'ai deux priorités en
terme d'emploi on n pas le temps de
décliner mais vous réinviterez hein moi
je veux me fixer je veux me fixer un
objectif voilà 200000 200000 chômeurs en
Bourgogne franchecé je pense que en en 6
ans on peut faire baisser le chômage de
10 % ce serait mon engagement il faut il
faut des engagements des résultats c'est
ça aussi que nous demandent nos
concitoyens je veux créer un nouveau un
nouveau type d'emploi pour les jeunes
les socialistes il faut changer ça on la
phobie de l'emploi public bien sûr qu'il
nous faut des administrations bien sûr
qu'il nous faut des emplois publics mais
il faut consacrer tout l'argent qu'on va
économiser tout l'argent qu'on va
prendre dans la machine les chiffres que
je viens de vous donner il faut les
mettre pour financer l'emploi des jeunes
dans les entreprises et je voudrais que
dans une période de 6 ans on puisse
faire rentrer 5000 5000 jeunes
supplémentaires en entreprise notamment
les jeunes de 18 à 25 ans qui n'ont pas
de formation et en même temps il faut
booster l'alternance j'ai rencontré
récemment un patron de CFA en code d'or
qui me disait toute la difficulté qu'il
avait à boucler son budget à la fin de
l'année les socialistes ont cassé
l'apprentissage maintenant ils nous
disent qu'il faut en faire plus et
j'étais dans ce CFA il lui manque 500000
€ par an sur un budget énorme le plus
gros CFA je veux pas citer le plus gros
CFA de Côte d'Or je peux vous dire que
si je suis président de la Région ça
sera ma priorité des priorités l'emploi
des jeunes c'est l'avenir de notre pays
c'est l'avenir de notre région autre
thème et c'est une question de d' de
viier pardonnez-moi si c'est pas comme
ça qu'il vousut proncer comment
comptez-vous développer les relations
intrarégionales notamment au niveau des
transports des voies de communication au
sein de la BoM franchecé bon sur ce
sujetl il y a déjà beaucoup de choses
qui existent j'en profite pour vous dire
d'ailleurs et je reviens sur le premier
sujet qu'entre Dijon et Besançon on a
plusieurs possibilités hein si on prend
le TGV ça fait une demi-heure si on
vient en voiture grosso modo ça fait
tr/4 d'heure et puis il y a aussi un
certain nombre de TER qui sont
d'ailleurs gérés par la région donc il y
a pas de souci de de développement je
pense que on a un certain nombre de
manque sur la Bourgogne franchecomée en
terme de voie de communication aussi
bien ferré d'ailleurs que que routière
je pense pas qu'on puisse rentrer dans
le détail ici mais je pense que euh on a
un accent tout particulier à mettre sur
les zones qui sont les plus les plus en
difficulté hein je pense à toute une
partie ouest euh de la de la Bourgogne
je pense à une partie est de de de la
franchectée je je connais bien tous ces
territoires on a un bel axe on a un bel
axe de de développement autour autour de
la 6 et puis de la 36 puisque cet axe
euh Dijon baun Macon Chalon qui remonte
dans le sens de de Besançon Belfort
voilà les deux dorsales de développement
de notre région ce qui manque c'est
l'irrigation en direction des
territoires il faut une équité dans les
territoires je pense qu'il faut faire un
effort pour mieux desservir un certain
nombre de départements qui sont un peu
éloignés de ces grands axes de
communication si vous ajoutez le à cela
le fait que la branche TGV qui a été
créé récemment et un peu parallèle à
cette dorsale que la branche sud du TGV
pour l'instant été abandonné par les
socialistes pour faire plaisir aux
écologistes vous voyez qu'on a aussi du
boulot à faire sur les voies de
communication euh pour les lycées parce
que c'est aussi une question vous avez
une ambition
particulière là aussi il y a une source
d'économie je le dis très franchement je
le dis sincèrement moi je veux pas dans
cette campagne je veux pas faire plaisir
à tout le monde mon but c'est pas de
faire plaisir à tout le monde c'est de
dire les choses avant pour les faire
après alors ça veut dire quoi pour ben
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui quand on
parle d'économie à faire quand vous
aurez dans cette région qui va compter
grosso modo 6000 salariés euh avec
toutes les personnes qui qui travaillent
dans les dans les lycées euh on sait
d'après le travail que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui vous avez à peu près 20 % de
M Carr en trop par élève on a en moyenne
26 m² 26 m² par élève dans les bâtiments
public imaginez le coût de de de la
gestion donc il est évident que il
suffit pas de de de de fusionner les
régions derrière il faut prendre les
décision qui s'impose pour rationaliser
et rationaliser la mécanique pas
diminuer le service public moi je je
suis un fan du service public j'ai
toujours mais ça veut dire éloigner les
lycées de de de C veut pas dire non ça
veut pas dire forcément éloigner les
lycées ça veut dire par exemple rendre
les bâtiments publics pluralistes vous
avez des formations par je prends un
exemple hein les formations au au Greta
des formations dans les lycées qui sont
les mêmes et c'est la région qui finance
les deux on va au Greta on va au lycée
est-ce qu'il peut pas y avoir à un
moment donné une fusion dans les mêmes
bâtiment d'un certain nombre d'activités
quand je vous dis que la fusion de cette
région c'est quasiment la fusion de de
entreprises aussi le premier pilier de
mon projet c'est celui qui va financer
les deux autres piliers et on n' pas eu
le temps de parler du rayonnement
international de l'excellence parce que
cette région il y a aussi de
l'excellence il faut il faut aussi
soutenir l'excellence c'est le rôle de
la région je pense à la culture bien
entendu je pense au patrimoine c'est
formidable je pense au sport de haut
niveau la région doit porter le sport de
haut niveau je voudrais bien que sur nos
trois équipes par exemple en football et
bien il y en a quand même une assez
rapidement qui reviennent dans qui
reviennent dans le top de la de la Ligue
1 il y a plein d'autres sports moi je
suis un sportif dans l'âme si je suis
président de cette région je vais
soutenir le sport de haut niveau voyez
il y a beaucoup de choses à faire sans
augmenter les impôts ça c'est un
engagement solennel quand j'ai été lu
maire de vezou j'ai dit je ferai petite
ville bien bien évidemment je ferai 500
emplois 500 logements et je baisserai
les impôts tous les ans on m'a dit il le
fera pas et ben je l'ai fait et je l'ai
fait et 17 ans plus tard la dernière
élection j'ai été élu par 61 % au
premier tour dans une ville de gauche
que j'ai j'ai pris aux socialistes pas
parce que c'est moi juste parce que on a
tenu avec mon équipe on a tenu nos
engagements les Françaises et les
Français ils veulent qu'on tiennent nos
engagements qu'on dire ce qu'on va faire
et qu'après on fasse ce que l'on a dit
enfin en quelques secondes vous vous y
croyez à l'identité de cette Bourgogne
franchecé avec je sais pas moi Macon qui
est plus attiré vers Lyon sens vers
Paris ne vers le centre bellefor vers la
je je ne crois pas à l'identité unique
je crois à un ajout des identités la
fusion administrative de deux ion ne
veut pas dire la perte d'identité au
contraire chacun doit garder son entité
chacun doit s'enrichir des différences
de l'autre et des ajouts de l'autre et
on voit bien si vous voulez que les
choses sont en marche et c'est nous qui
devons porter nous à l'UMP
principalement qui devons porter ce
message comment on l'a portter aux
élections départementales vous savez je
pense que on doit mettre fin c'est ça
aussi mon engagement politique ma
passion pour faire les choses positives
j'aime pas la j'aime pas la critique
mais on doit quand même mettre fin à
cette gestion socialiste qui qui
administratise les régions qui
administratise l'état on voit bien le on
voit bien le résultat au niveau national
on voit le résultat j'ai pas été trop
caricatural mais franchement le résultat
de 10 ans de gestion socialiste c'est
quand même pas très très reluisant donc
vraiment je le dis à ceux qui nous
écoutent moi j'ai besoin de tous ceux
qui veulent m'aider pour participer avec
d'autres le l'alternance est en route et
comme dirait quelqu'un que j'aime bien
c'est-à-dire Nicolas Sarkozi rien ne
l'arrêtera et ben il nous reste une
minute en gros justement vous me tendez
la perche bouclons la boucle vous êtes
certain d'aller au bout Alain Joyandet
aujourd'hui là vous pouvez dire je vais
aller au bout de ma candidature mais
bien sûr que je vais aller au bout de ma
candidature est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous en doutez vous je j'observe et bien
moi je nen doute à aucun moment voilà je
suis vraiment très enthousiaste et
j'appelle tous ceux qui veulent nous
rejoindre pas qu'à l'UMP parce que vous
savez dans les gens qui nous soutiennent
il y a beaucoup de gens qui n'ont pas de
carartte dans les partis politiques il y
a beaucoup de gens qui sont désorientés
qui savent plus à quel sin voouer qui
disent bon la droite la gauche c'est
pareil ils nous ont dit des choses ils
les ont pas fait donc on va voir Marine
Le Pen moi je leur dis faites-nous
confiance on va faire les choses on va
les dire on les fera après et vous êtes
prêt à discuter avec François sa mais
bien sûr écoutez franchement nous étions
dans la même classe au lycée Montchapet
dans la même classe au lycée monchap on
avait la même blouse blan la même grande
blouse bleue à l'époque dans ce lycée
d'ailleurs qui testait à l'époque tout
au début
l'autodiscipline voyez et
l'autodiscipline au fond c'est un peu la
règle de la Rép public parce que dans
l'autodiscipline qu'est-ce qu'il y a et
bien il y a la liberté il y a la
responsabilité et moi cette cette France
que j'aime c'est celle de la liberté de
la responsabilité et de l'entreprise et
un appelle à François savadet à
l'autodiscipline donc merci beaucoup
Alain Joyandet on arrive déjà au terme
de cette émission merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation je vous rappelle que
vous pouvez voir ou revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet
bourgon.france3.fr la semaine prochaine
nous reparlerons de la fusion des
régions bourgan franchecé au cours d'une
émission spéciale
plus spécifiquement consacré à la
capitale de la future région en présence
des mares de Dijon et de Besançon donc
Alain mot et Jean-Louis Fousseret
notamment rendez-vous des 11h samedi
prochain d'ici là très bon weekend à
[Musique]
tous